you mentioned atheists are you uh are
you an open atheist I was just at the
reason rally in DC last weekend and it
was all atheists getting together at our
race and rally at the reason rally Oh
raisin rally the race ants to me like
why did they love dry grapes so much
yeah yeah I'm sorry that's what there's
probably a metaphor a raisin no raisin
and reason I'm sure there's somebody I
think what if you think you should race
I might have said anyway anyway I've had
very difficult anyway different rallies
oh yeah and there's a lot of atheists
there and they want to promote atheism
do you think atheism should be promoted
or is it just your sort of private view
of things uh it's not even a necessarily
a private view of things for me I mean
not I you know I don't it's not like
yeah does this blowhards that like my
faith is very personal good right get
the rose talking about it good cuz no
one gives a [ __ ] yeah I'm glad it's
personal cuz I'll never ask you a
question about it or anything else right
dude I don't hate that person I I hate
them I don't know why the faith is
personal I have those people my wife's
my best friend the people that call
their house their home and and their kid
their children like when you come into
my home in front of my children I hate I
hate that all right now I'm an atheist
just because I never was introduced to
any form of religion growing up or at
any time in my life so and so I figure
you need to either grow up you know oh
this guy was a Mormon growing up you
know like oh you know you get it like oh
you grow up in this religion and then if
you back that out of the equation then
you need some sort of catastrophic event
right right though I was blacked out
drunk I drove through that retirement
home
I took 84 souls and now I gotta somehow
get right again with the universe so I
will find Jesus Christ and then I'll
apologize them and he'll forgive me and
then I'll get I'll get to get on with my
life right some things
the average person that if they hadn't
been introduced to religion you really
have no reason to come to it right like
there's no real reason short of some
catastrophic thing or some health thing
or something like that
where then you'd need something else I
feel like not growing up around it not
having a catastrophic event um not even
sort of hitting rock bottom emotionally
like like hey I'm rudderless I don't
know where to go with myself like I
don't know what my you know what am i
doing on this planet you know what I
mean um and or the rarified air of
somebody you know like you're Muhammad
Ali in the Nation of Islam goes hey man
what a cool game o ty yeah I'm on down
yeah or you know maybe you're Tom Cruise
and somebody comes you know like there
are religions that the rarified air of
like that might recruit the celebrity mm
which I'm open to so if the right people
came you're not you're not above having
the Mormons come in and say you know
will sponsor your place yeah and then by
the way I'll get no conversation with
them just like you know a blue-chip
recruit would might be like well that's
our that's that's great you know a a
couple hindu guys dropped off an
Escalade yeah kind of had a bow on it
yeah uh it said was all taken care of so
you know it's a nice ride but if you can
do better with like a Porsche Cayenne or
something like that you know I'm all
ears
yeah you know your dumb million basket
in like n-c-double-a those that start
doing it with you know I hear me talking
about the hindu guy yeah Verena sure
okay Baba gonna yeah I don't know that's
the poverty might happen to be a lunch
table the point is is yeah once I
declare major you know what I mean once
I put the cap on that has the religion
on and I say I'm taking my talents over
to Hinduism yeah you know that that kind
of thing who is signing bonus assigning
what's pretty good you know we pulled
their ceremonial garb over my
three-piece suit
photo-op my mom's crying my dad's not
there of course ya never met the man
no no but the point is is we we do that
I get coached up and then I start in a
wearing the Hat kind of working it in
you know and I think it'd be worth the
SUV and whatever kind of Wham what I
call walking around money that religion
might provide right so you're not above
selling out which is a and you're
upfront about it's a kind of beautiful
thing
well again I'm an atheist so I I can go
any direction I want and then sleep like
a baby
yeah animes I don't really answer
anybody unless the price is right so one
of the things you do on your podcast is
you talk to people regardless of whether
you agree with them or disagree with
them that that's pretty much what we
talked about Co regardless but but it's
irregardless isn't that pretty sure are
we gonna disagrees in the irregardless
the made-up word it's yours it's
regardless here regardless it's
irregardless I just say that to scare ya
always make sure I'm pretty sure that's
a made-up word but the point is
irregardless about God most of that yeah
um but you taught you like hold on I've
I've just done it I've just come around
and done a complete 360 on this
irregardless its regardless Janna its
180 i'ma go you'll say anyway see uh you
know I used to be against gay marriage
and then I did a whole 360 on it right
now now I'm for it yeah and it's like no
no no your back - yeah people are idiots
is that the main thing do you have cuz
that's pretty much I walk around all day
and I watch the news and I listen to
people and I think 90% I look on Twitter
90% of people are just morons is that
fair to say well 90% of people don't
have clearly thought-out positions
yeah like they're just sitting there
going you know I don't know how many
chicks are spoken to it like I don't
like hunting and I don't like hunters
and you're like well these guys go on
this you know shoot some deer and then
they eat it you know what right wrong
with that I I don't I fix I don't think
it's right and you go wait a minute you
eat beef right right yeah
you eat steak right you we ate in and
out two days yeah
well so what this guy you know what
Chris Pratt goes out and shoots a deer
and then he makes deer jerky out of it
and then he gives it his friends and
then actually some people shoot the deer
and they give the meat to a homeless
shelter yeah I know I know I just I just
don't I don't like it I disagree with it
it's like what are you disagreeing with
you eat you you're eating a hamburger
you're eating jerky right now and
they're like you just snapped into a
slim jim while we were talking about
that they're like I know I just I don't
and it's like well how about you either
think or shut the [ __ ] up yeah well I
don't know what are we talking about you
know and you go I don't I don't agree
with Harris Jayma and Nagasaki I could I
don't think anyone wakes up in the
morning and wants to have a nuclear bomb
dropped on them I just I don't and then
they start doing this stupid math look
like do you would you like it if you
woke up and someone dropped the bomb on
your head and you go okay well what
we're gonna do we're gonna invade Japan
like we were gonna kill 500,000 to a
million people we're going to kill a
bunch of them and women and children and
would have been the slaughter fest
or we can drop a bomb and take those
numbers and decrease them significantly
yeah I disagree I don't think you should
drop nuclear bombs
okay well now give me your plan you
ready give me your plan and the answer
so it's like oh I'm not it I don't know
yeah I don't not in war I don't know I
but my plan is like nuts just don't have
the war at all yeah I know but they
bombed Pearl Harbor so what do you want
us to do well I'm disagree I wouldn't
eat me I mean I enjoy me do you have any
pork on you yeah I don't like hunters
yeah it's like people just talk so it's
really that people don't people don't
really think through there
no like when that gorillas yeah that's
perfect ample um left it's cave that
morning it wasn't planning on being shot
yeah no no
how would you like it if you just walked
out with your slippers and bathrobe to
get a newspaper and someone just put a
bullet in your head I don't think you'd
like would you like bad would you
deserve that that's it gorilla didn't
deserve to get shot no gorilla should be
left behind I see what you're doing
there and then you go well what are we
gonna do there's holding a
three-year-old well are you gonna do I I
don't I'm not a zoo personality it's you
I I don't trains you to person yeah but
you got a note anything but shoot the
thing it doesn't you know maybe you
shoot it in the thigh do the gorillas
have thighs right I'm not a zoo person -
Zoop ow oh shoot it all right well if
that makes it Maddon and it starts
throwing the kid around like a rag doll
he's anything but you don't kill it
gorilla yeah kill it
didn't that story kind of like get to
how stupid everything is because I saw
all these people immediately you have to
tranquilize it you have to tranquilize
it yeah and then and then experts came
on and experts said well the gorilla is
so big there would have been the time
between where it could have just grabbed
the kid and killed it like that you
could not have tranquilized it nobody
was saying we were for shooting it that
they weren't thrilled to shoot it right
you made the point that gorilla was this
a good animal that nobody wanted to kill
maybe it wasn't
maybe it had done some [ __ ] maybe I
guess domestic abuse in the past yeah so
yeah it's not any possibly deserved well
are all gorillas the best in on a man oh
now you're making the all argument and
maybe this one was it maybe this one you
know was a c-minus student who'd smack
this old light around a little bit we
don't know what about the mother because
people were freaking out on the mother
how could you lose your kid in a gorilla
thing you're your son is right here
hello yeah he's in the studio ace he
turned 10 yesterday he turned 10 I'm
sure you know he can get into spots that
you can't suddenly get him right yeah
what if he jumped into a gorilla thing
what would you do
uh you know just look you want to look
at him while you're sorry
I raised you well enough you're smart
enough to know better so I just let
Norwin take out the trash yes basically
I'm hands-off here you know we don't
need him reproducing at 10 if he's dumb
enough he's dumb enough you know when
you're 3 okay I cut you some slack yeah
I mean like it and uh if that happened
when you're 3 Sonny I would have like
immediately snapped into action like I
would have for sure like thrown my shoe
down there 1 hit him with it you know I
mean I've said I want to get in there
myself
right right uh-huh but you know I would
have certainly thrown like a granola bar
down therefore you're gonna be down
there for length of time yeah probably
at some point alerted some officials but
obviously because of my celebrity status
I'd probably have to work through my
publicist first and try to Yap out a
strategy you know you know I've ride
into these things and mixing you know
you're splashed all over the headlines
bad father you know and I probably wait
you know I'm not a CHP patrolman but you
know I did Loveline for a while I sat
next to dr. drew is addiction medicine
specialist I dunno there's a part when
you consume alcohol where you will
actually test lower because you haven't
absorbed the alcohol and then there's
another part where you're tested you
know breathalyzer where you're actually
lower words passed through your system
so I'd probably give it a waiting period
till the alcohol that whatever alcohol
I'm assuming if I'm at the zoo I'm Bob
right yes otherwise if sober walking
around that with those giraffes it's
like la zoos it yeah it does like some
sort of weird detention center from the
future is horrible I haven't been there
yet that's a disaster don't don't go
there they're gonna have a place it just
sells churros and it has to work Hut
behind the word churro a churro Hut it's
a disaster has nothing to do a job of
that has nothing to do but the people
that eat there are fatter than Jabba the
Hutt so I
just to beat quickly answer your
question wait - my alcohol level went
down
I don't need hey drunk and you know
c-lister let his kid fall the thing I
talked to my representation and then
alert officials and then after that you
know I'm not a zoo / as you I you know
zoo person the expert the arson so I've
let the zoo whatever their title is I'd
let them handle it yeah but I don't
blame them up yeah you know here's what
I don't blame the mom um because those
people who eat the hamburgers but don't
like the hunters right who hate nuclear
devices but have no solution to the
thousands hundreds of thousand people be
slaughtered on the mainland of Japan and
who if that kid fell into the gorilla
pit and somehow was extracted and the
gorilla was fine or even got one of
those airplane donut pillows and out of
it yeah then those people wouldn't be
calling for the head of the mother so
the gorilla gets shot in the head and
now we need mamas head to roll way I
look at it is Mama's role is the same
one gorilla is not harmed the other
gorilla takes a bullet to the head
Mama's role didn't change so my feeling
is just because the gorilla got shot
doesn't it doesn't change Mama's actions
interesting so we're just looking for
constant moral superiority to everybody
right is that what it is like every time
something happens everyone gets on yeah
it's just crazy outrage like look I what
happened to Cecil the lion
how many blowhards who took to the
sweetest Ville and decided to write
something heroic down yeah we're now
volunteering at the animal shelter or
I'm gonna guess working with the big
felines or anything or even remember
what the story was yeah but Dad this was
I I don't get it like people are like
aren't you outraged and I'm like no
they're like why and I'm like since
we've been talking about Cecil five
lines have been killed and then three
lines killed five human beings that
that's my cosmic man yeah but I've done
your ballpark I know that guy
yeah I don't go into some sort of
depression spiral every time an animal
was shot I'd be pretty miserable dude
yeah but now people are gonna say well
Adam Carolla hates animals but that's
not what you're saying
here's ears right there yeah I like
people and I don't care about animals to
the extent that I turn them into human
beings yeah I care about you know in
order of appearance I care about myself
yeah I think I'm top three actually yeah
then then the boy he's not even paying
attention or don't worry about that yeah
you're head of your sister yeah is that
vinegar you know I got my wife uh like
nanny wife work gardener in there anyway
uh valued employees yeah and friends
ex-lovers jimmy kimmel you know it
sounds like yes eventually it gets to
Americans wait you put him above dr.
drew just for the record oh man
I love them both but Kimmel throws a
better party yeah all right our stud
it's Super Bowl event yeah I would
imagine there's more drinking and drugs
that went to his parties then then dr.
drew he has he has a full bar yeah he
has like five taps well in one of them
just cocaine come ha ha ha I'm so
awesome yeah I just see like Ben Affleck
and Matt Damon just a lot actually Matt
was like just laying under his bed was
yeah it's awesome they didn't have he
didn't have that from the man show money
that's the ABC money yeah no he's got
the ultimate which I always like to say
you know people think a few money [ __ ]
you money aliment ultimate is [ __ ] me
money is
you know me like I can do stuff that's
so stupid and it doesn't matter yeah you
know like when you've got some of that
money right I am you've got some limited
yeah no I do stuff all the time like
people honestly like when people say you
know what's the best part about having
money of being rich or doing well being
well-off or whatever and is it like it
is it driving a nice cars that having a
cool house is it going on a vacation or
whatever and if you really think about
it most people can afford you can get in
get an Audi s4 that's three years old
and afford it and have a cool fast car
to drive around or old Porsche whatever
like then anyone can hop on a Southwest
flight find a B&B in San Francisco and
eat all-you-can-eat sushi night or
whatever like most people can afford
like at this time know the best part
about having money is eff me money which
I thought through all time like I've had
a couple of [ __ ] neighbors and just
people around that like [ __ ] who
lived underneath me and it's like
there's a bunch of bunch of mud in my
pool you caused it and it's a-you know
irrigation line broke and blah blah blah
and I'm an attorney and I'm not a big
celebrity like you and I don't do a home
improvement show sure would look bad you
know and I know where you live I moved
in blah blah blah and I said he
literally says like just give me ten
thousand dollars of this this will go
away and or I'll see in court and this
guy's a shyster yeah it a moral piece of
[ __ ] and I was like no let the insurance
guy go let the adjuster show up the
house that by the way is torrential rain
for the three nights before that that's
where the mud came from I didn't have
anything break he just wanted me to fix
his pool yeah and his attorney should be
tossed out of the bar but anyway the bar
doesn't police anybody but here's where
that [ __ ] you money comes in and I did
it to this horrible witch who bought
another house of mine who was trying to
sue me for cracked foundation three
years after I sold her the house
and they're doing like hearings and
stuff and I said hey you know their
whole thing is like give me ten thousand
dollars it'll go away give me 25 grand
it'll go away here's where that [ __ ] me
money comes in I'll spend a hundred
grand on attorney way faster than I'll
give you ten thousand dollars right way
faster so you'd rather have me money
yeah I'm down 90 grand and I don't give
a [ __ ]
yeah because I like morality better than
I like money and I will definitely by
the way neither shyster got a penny
because they're not going to sue because
they can't sue because they don't have a
[ __ ] case but the point is is I am
perfectly willing to give Mark Geragos
$100,000 not to give you $8,000 yeah I
don't think arrow goes needs that much
money he's got a lot of he's got a legal
that would be what he calls ashtray yeah
yeah that's nothing for him all right
let's plow through some just like
hot-button stuff since we're all over
the place here at election let's not
about Cecil poor C's I know talking
about that I know people like I always
tell people all the time I
you don't have enough air in your lungs
to get me to care and then by the way
not only do I not care I know you don't
care and here's how I know you don't
care seven weeks from now I'll ask you
about Cecil Nia go whoo yeah Chuck Cecil
the DB from Atlanta back in the 80s know
the line remember remember you're in
tears and you're writing all those
tweets yeah oh yeah that's Cecil yeah
what happened to him well I think these
people look I felt bad for the lion but
these people that are boycotting the
dentist that they had never heard of the
day before and now you're outside
picketing this dentist whom elementally
shot the animal that didn't realize it
was that animal you know you boycott a
dentist I see the joke's on you yeah you
know no man I'm not gonna get my teeth
clean for a hundred years right right
that's gonna cause you problems yeah I
mean if you need root canal you should
not be boy only thing we got that does
yeah I don't I don't listen it's as
simple I don't even know why we need to
go through this [ __ ] dance where I
go I'm not for the killing of innocent
lions yeah okay good now it happened
let's move on I'm not for the killing of
gorillas
now it happened move on I'm not for the
bombing of Japanese cities now it
happened let's try to do something real
yeah like that that's what that's thing
I love the way you have to explain
yourself as if you just like you want it
you want a line or gorilla burger I'm
Brooklyn
you